إنه ذلك الوقت من العام مرة أخرى، حيث يشكل فيروس RSV
covid-19 والأنفلونزا تهديدًا ثلاثيًا محتملاً
هذا الخريف، نريد أن نستبق
الأمر ونشجع الناس على الحصول على
لقاح الأنفلونزا الآن، في موسم الأنفلونزا الماضي، كان هناك ما
لا يقل عن 27 مليون حالة أنفلونزا، و300000 حالة نقل إلى
المستشفى و  19000 حالة وفاة
مرتبطة بالأنفلونزا بينما تقول المراكز الأمريكية
لمكافحة الأمراض والوقاية منها أن
التطعيمات تقلل من خطر
دخول المستشفى ضد الأنفلونزا بنحو 50 بالمائة،
أقل من نصف البلاد حصلت على لقاح الأنفلونزا
الموسم الماضي، ويقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إن شهري سبتمبر
وأكتوبر هما الأوقات المثالية
بعد التطعيم، نتوقع في الواقع أن
لقاح الأنفلونزا المتوفر لدينا
سيعمل بشكل جيد للغاية وسيكون
فعالًا للغاية بمجرد وصول الأنفلونزا إلى نصف
الكرة الشمالي، يقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إن
مجتمعات الأمريكيين من أصل أفريقي واللاتينيين معرضون بشكل أكبر لخطر
النتائج الخطيرة من الأنفلونزا.  الأنفلونزا ولكن
كانت احتمالية الحصول على التطعيم أقل،
ويُعتقد أن العوائق مثل نقص التأمين أو وسائل النقل وعدم القدرة على الإقلاع من العمل لعبت
دورًا. تتوفر لدى
مراكز صحة المجتمع التابعة لوزارة الصحة بالولاية والصيدليات المحلية
جميعها لقاحات الأنفلونزا للعثور عليها
تقول الوكالة الأقرب إليك للتحقق من موقع
getmyflueshot.org، إنها طريقة للاستعداد
لمعرفة أن الأنفلونزا
قادمة من أجل الصحة، أنا آندي
جايثر أجنبي